Turquía ha comenzado esta pasada
madrugada una campaña de bombardeos en
contra de todo el norte de Irak y todo
el norte sería sobre todo en contra de
las milicias kurdas ideas de las yepegué
y la guerrilla curóturca del peca casta
guerrilla crudo turca lleva desde la
década de los 80 en guerra contra
Turquía en una guerra en la que ha
habido cerca de 40.000 Muertos las
yepeguesías son vinculadas hasta que ríe
del pkk pero han sido las usadas por
Estados Unidos en la guerra en contra
del estado islámico Estados Unidos y las
yepega hicieron una alianza que sigue
hasta la fecha y estas yepe que
controlan gran parte del noreste de
Siria Turquía ha empezado esta campaña
de bombardeos después de una semana
exacta del atentado de Estambul en la
calle disticlava en la que murieron seis
civiles en una explosión que Turquía
acusa como responsables a estas yepegué
y apk de estas dos organizaciones lo
niegan completamente y aseguran no tener
nada que ver con este ataque sin embargo
Turquía realizado este ataque después de
que erdogan supuestamente explicado el
Ministerio de defensa aprobase esta
operación en su vuelta desde Indonesia
donde atendió el g20 y se espera que
esos bombardeos Pueden seguir en los
próximos días aunque sean no han
explicado Fuentes del Ministerio de
defensa Turco no hay de momento a una
operación terrestre como se ha habido en
el pasado Turquía ha hecho tres
operaciones terrestres en contra de
pegue en China por momentos esto no está
ocurriendo son solo ataques aéreos que
pueden durar varios días más pero de
momento no se espera que llegue una
ofensiva terrestre en los próximos días
semanas o incluso meses donde Sí podría
llegar antes de las elecciones turcas en
junio de 2023